ich sage auch nach dem was ich in den
letzten wochen in der ukraine gesehen
habe nämlich dass die westlichen waffen
endlich einen unterschied machen vor
acht wochen als sie eine aus der ukraine
war da haben mir die offiziere dort
gesagt wir können uns nicht verteidigen
gegen die russische art wie wir haben
einfach viel zu wenig tatsächlich sieht
man jetzt nicht unbedingt die zwölf
panzerhaubitzen aus deutschland die auch
aber das sind natürlich viel zu wenige
aber us-waffen die einen großen
unterschied machen in den vergangenen
tagen wir sehen dass die frontlinie dort
von den ukrainern besser gehalten werden
kann ich glaube wir müssen jetzt
unbedingt mehr liefern denn die
frontlinie ist lang es sind fast 2000
kilometer es braucht dringend weitere
es braucht dringend moderne waffen auf
der ganzen linie damit die ukraine sich
dort verteidigen kann denn immer noch
ist es so dass russland langsam aber
stetig voran kommt bestimmte dörfer dort
einnimmt und das bedeutet wenn wir
nichts tun dann ist der gesamte dombach
bald verloren da sind wir noch
zurückhaltend mit den waffenlieferungen
aus deutschland
naja ich muss ihnen ehrlich sagen
solange der bundeskanzler nicht in der
lage ist mal in einer rede auch klar zu
formulieren was er möchte sondern nach
wie vor immer vom ringtausch spricht und
das als ein seiner haut abgestimmt sagte
halles eine fein abgestimmte bekommen
ringtausch spricht sind wir gefühlt weit
weg von dem was paul ronzheimer
anspricht und ich bin ich teile diese
position persönlich dass auch hier
erkenntlich geworden ist ich glaube mit
dem panzerhaubitzen war es jetzt
nachvollziehbar das modernere geräte
auch zu mehr territorialen gewinn führen
und wenn man sich allein anschaut wie
viele verletzte soldaten wir haben ich
glaube bis zu 7000 1500 die sterben dann
sind das situation wo wir dringend bei
der größe auch der armee die derzeit an
der frontlinie ist mit entsprechend
guten gerät
eine unterstützung leisten können und
müssen wir sind in der frage nicht
erwarten
also mir hat mein fdp politiker gesagt
auf die frage was sollen wir denn
eigentlich liefern wir haben nichts und
werden sie dafür sagen also was haben
wir denn überhaupt liefern was haben wir
denn ich kenne die inventarliste nicht
insoweit kann ich ihnen nicht sagen was
das was im bestand ist ich kann ihnen
nur sagen die erste strategie war der
sogenannte ringtausch dass man sozusagen
all das was ihn verwendet werden kann
aus alten gerät in die ukraine geht
dahinter steckt ja nichts anderes und
das ist ja eine formulierung die der
bundeskanzler scholz bei jeder
gelegenheit verwendet windows geräte mit
denen die ukraine umgehen konnten genau
über die verlage gegen sprechen wie
können wir jetzt mit modernem gerät
vor ort für unterstützung sorgen und wir
wollen diese unterstützung wir haben das
klar formuliert unsere
verteidigungspolitische sprecherin
und vorsitzender verteidigungsausschuss
hat das getan agnes strack zimmermann
sehr deutlich und das ist auch unsere
haltung auch gegenüber dem
bundeskanzleramt
ich stimme dir davon zu haben meint ihre
unterstützung aber es nutzt ja nichts
wenn wir eine
bundesverteidigungsministerium wie heißt
sie noch lamprecht glaube ich ja die
also immer nur erklärt was alles nicht
geht dass man es ja unglaublich viel tun
dass ich aber nicht im einzelnen sagen
könne die sich also zur lächerlichen
figur macht wenn sie aus dem bundestag
versucht um gewisse panzer als nicht
panzer zu erklären also rohre die
irgendwohin schießen und woanders
unterkommen das klingt als wäre die frau
auf dem rummelplatz und wird erklären
wie also eine schießbude funktioniert
und es geht hier wirklich um den einsatz
der bundeswehr eine tüchtige der
bundeswehr und militärische hilfe für
ein land im unter überlebenskampf also
solange ich eine solche frau in dieser
situation mit dieser aufgabe betrauen da
ist mir das einfach nicht wichtig genug
da muss ich einfach den vorwurf an die
ampel machen anderen scholz an alle so
lange an der frau lamprecht als spitze
der ehemaligen hatte als das
bundesverteidigungsministerium festhält
so lang ist ein eigentlich das nicht so
furchtbar wichtig in welchem zustand die
bundeswehr sich befindet mit welcher
militärischen unterstützung zieht der
ukraine beim überleben helfen kann das
ist so eine theoretische diskussion ich
meine alle parteien fdp cdu spd grüne
haben dazu beigetragen dass über zwölf
jahre lang die bundeswehr wirklich
völlig und man ja klar aus einer schuld
sagt er ist halt nicht ändern dann setzt
er vor lampe dabei ist ein großer
geldgeber protokoll wir können uns über
personalien lasst uns aber die fakten
reden es ist nichts da was man sozusagen
verteilen könnte jetzt haben wir 100
millionen 9 milliarden programm das
umgesetzt wird das dauert jahre die
fehler der vergangenheit kann man eben
leider nicht so schnell korrigieren wie
wir auch die fehler in der
energiepolitik nicht innerhalb von
wenigen wochen quer fahren wollen das
haben die waffen liefern könnte ja
natürlich muss man auch sehen dass auf
der anderen seite haben wir jetzt
festgestellt ein irrationaler diktator
ist ja und das risiko hat mit sicherheit
olaf scholz jeden tag abzuwägen wie weit
habe ich schaden vom deutschen volk
abzuwenden das ist artikel 56 der
deutschen verfassung nicht er hat ja
nicht auf die ukrainische verfassung
sein alt geleitet sondern auch die
deutsche verfassung und ist
verantwortlich für uns das ist uns nicht
in den orkus reist haben sie das gefühl
dass manche politiker in deutschland zu
wenig gerade am herzen liegt naja
zumindest kann man ja festhalten wir
sind einen langen weg schon gegangen
früher war es eine doktrin in
kriegsgebiete werden wir keine waffen
liefern mittlerweile tun wir das aus
guten gründen das kritisiere ich nicht
aber ich finde wir müssen noch
irgendwann mal sehen dass wir in einer
selbst geschaffenen zwangssituation sind
wir sind erpressbar geworden und das ist
nicht mit starken worten einfach vom
tisch zu fegen das ist so und da muss
man sich dann auch entsprechend so
verhalten dass man nicht sozusagen sein
eigenes volk in den untergrund was man
ja leute pressberger die erpressbarkeit
ist zum beispiel die abstellung des
gases das ist der mangel sie müssen sich
einfach mal vorstellen was das bedeutet
wenn sie eine pipeline abstellen der
vorsitzende des des verband der
chemischen industrie hat uns das mal
erklärt er hat gesagt das ist ein wahn
kessel zug von frankfurt bis sie will ja
nur für die chemische industrie nicht
für alle anderen nur für die chemische
industrie und dann müssen sie mal raten
für wie lange den erreicht das reicht
für sechs tage damit wir wissen über
welche dimensionen wir reden das ist
dann nicht ein paar schiefgehen war zu
ersetzen das geht leider nicht und es
wird auch dann noch schlimmer wenn man
dann auch noch kämpfen während er gerade
bei der waffen diskussion werden wir
gerade über die angefragte
welche welche schwierigkeiten entstehen
und welche abwägungen müssen wir
vornehmen und die schiffchen für sie
sind ist das sind die lng terminals oder
was wichtig den
g7 bringen dann war genau da aus dieser
haltung müssen wir haben da müssen wir
machen das ja jahrelang gemacht damit
ich doch dafür nur wir müssen sehen das
abstellen von kernkraftwerken bringt
mehr als ein solo in griesheim bei der
nasa hat bei der bisher genau und bei
der frage der abwägung nicht verstehe
auch da verstehe ich den deutschen kurs
nicht man gibt ein bisschen
aber nicht genügend um die ukraine der
ukraine tatsächlich so zu unterstützen
dass sie tatsächlich territorium halten
kann und es ist nicht ganz richtig dass
wir alles liefern was wir können das
machen wir eben nicht da gibt es sehr
viele beispiele für es gibt auch das
beispiel von rheinmetall der also dass
man sozusagen mit der waffenproduktion
der ukraine helfen könnte also dass sie
selbst diese waffen dort erwerben all
das passiert nicht und da frage ich mich
warum glaubt olaf scholz macht das jetzt
ein unterschied wenn er sagt er schickt
12 panzerhaubitzen aber fiktiv gesagt
nicht 100
moment ich will ja nur ich sage ja
fiktiven als beispiel dafür
dieser glaube dass wladimir putin dort
im kreml sitzt und irgendwie nach zählt
wie viele waffen wie es geschickt haben
und deswegen irgendwie wütender oder
noch wütender oder besonders wütend auf
deutschland ist den habe ich nie
verstanden und das war ja auch das was
olaf scholz gesagt hat er gibt so ein
bisschen das soll auch nicht auffallen
und dann sah redet man auch nicht
darüber weil dann könnte putin ja böse
werden ja also das verstehe ich
überhaupt nicht dass es das eine und das
zweite dieses argument was ja auch sehr
häufig kommt in der waffen diskussion ja
die waffen könnten daher getroffen
werden also alle waffen die ich dort an
davon gesehen habe deutsche waffen
us-waffen sie wurden nicht getroffen
über schienen netzwerk in der ukraine
kommt dass dort sehr sicher rein und das
ist bewiesen worden also sollten wir
mehr tun wenn wir denn der überzeugung
sind und wenn wir dann wollen dass die
ukraine diesen krieg gewinnt wenn wir
das nicht wollen dann sollten wir dort
gewinnen ist für dich mit den gewinnen
win ist für mich großen an die grenze zu
bringen wieder na ja zumindest auf das
gebiet vor dem 23 februar so ich bin
aber sehr ins gewicht dass sie lebt und
nicht auch so lenski will das auch da
habe ich das andere geht das ist ein
mittelfristiges langfristiges ziel was
natürlich die ukraine hat alle täter
hatten teile das habt ihr doch angeboten
nein das war nicht angeboten grimm und
don was war doch man hatte doch ist
jedoch zurückgepfiffen wurden älteren
istanbul dieses thema mit chrisam und da
muss mehr ich glaube da kommen wir jetzt
eine sehr tiefe diskussion der
kambodscha dann gab es keine
genau diesen großen kriegsverbrechen
aber noch einmal zurück zu der zu der
waffen frage ich glaube dass es wirklich
eine ganz entscheidende frage die wir
uns auch als deutsche stellen müssen
wollen wir dass die ukraine im stande
ist dort erfolgreich zu sein oder nicht
wenn wir das an ihre grenze wo flugzeuge
liefern wollen wir auch dort mal so
verbotszone machen dann sind wir
kriegsparteien wollen sie nichts partei
sie darüber reden ich habe nie eine
flugverbotszone gefordert ich war immer
dagegen ich finde dass wir zum beispiel
durchaus panzer liefern sollten marder
panzer zum beispiel das ist glaube ich
dringend notwendig aber ich habe ja
diese frage viel allgemeiner formuliert
weil ich glaube die ist sehr
entscheidend wenn wir das nicht wollen
und nicht daran glauben dass die ukraine
diesen krieg gewinnen kann dann müssen
wir eine andere strategie fahren als
bundesregierung aber dieses von allem
ein bisschen und nicht zu viel das
funktioniert nicht gab heute ein sehr
spannendes zitat von frau berbalk
gelesen im stern und zwar vorüber kann
man mit jemandem verhandeln der nicht
mal bereit ist mit dem internationalen
komitee vom roten kreuz humanitäre
korridore für die flüchtlinge für die
flucht von zivilisten zu ermöglichen und
das verfahren heute hat mich zum
beispiel schon auch zum nachdenken
angeregt wie weit können wir wissen dass
man mit putin verhandeln die heimliche
angetriebenen verteidigen mir geht es
nur darum geht ihr in der debatte ich
habe wirklich überhaupt keine interessen
zu verteidigen ich habe auch
klar gesagt ich diese von dem von den
barbarischen krieg seien aber die frage
die ich hier bitte berücksichtigen ein
bundeskanzler muss in dem ganzen konzert
in der gesamt politik der verantwortung
die er hat immer wissen dass er auch so
zu sagen wenn er eingreift wenn er
sanktionen macht das die nicht am ende
dazu führen dass wir schlechter dran
sind mehr getroffen werden als die die
er treffen will und mehr verlangen